the books you like
are all the books i love so i have to
mention this you mentioned uh briefly on
the
with jordan uh siddhartha by herman
hesse
is a is an incredible book yeah there
i mean i don't i don't know exactly what
i want to ask here but there's some
i think the book kind of
through telling a story yeah reveals
that
life is suffering and yet there's beauty
in it the beauty in every moment it
uses kind of a river yeah painted
metaphor is there
is there um is there something that you
could say
speak to like how that book impacted
your life and the way you live life
maybe the way you
see life whether it's on the life of
suffering side or that life is beautiful
side
i mean he goes the entire journey right
he goes in this day like i'm so
enlightened that
i cannot deal with the people they're in
love and cry about it
right they're like that's so like
primitive
once he has his own son he actually
being attached
he actually cares he actually really
does her thing
right that's the thing that he used to
think not once his son comes find him
he looks at life differently i think
that's the thing i did have the kind of
journey where
oh nothing matters right so bitter so
so like so cynical and
after i met so many incred incredible
people i was talking about that
person who told me he was gay he told
me i love you and i was like why do you
love me
in the past people when they wanted me
was because they want to rape me
everybody wanted something from me
that's why they wanted me
and i never understood you can love
somebody unconditionally
and this gay guy the last one was going
to sleep with me right
and he loves me and i think
i had a blessing after my journey
meeting people who
loved me unconditionally because i was
just being a human
and i think that's what it is now for me
that like him
i live for love now i live for love any
kind of love love for knowledge
i like i read so many books because i
love books right
i love what i do i love my people i love
humanity
you know even it sometimes annoys me
i love myself and that's beautiful too
the annoying parts are beautiful too
you